[Music]
I'm here from materialise Inc I'm the
chief scientist at materialise we are
building something which I'm gonna tell
you about now I'm gonna tell you my take
on on what we're making there's some
contact information up now there'll be
some links and stuff as we go but
there's all this information will be
again at the end of the talk so don't
get stressed out at the moment about you
know grabbing anything down or wandering
off onto your phone so what I'm gonna
tell you about that we're building at
materialises we call the sequel view
maintenance engine it's the title of the
talk that's me materialize and perhaps
some of you are scratching ahead perhaps
not but perhaps some of you're
scratching your head saying what's
what's a sequel view maintenance engine
and so I'm gonna talk through that let
me talk through how it comes to pass why
you might want such a thing what sorts
of problems does it solve and what
opportunities does it open up that you
might not have imagined before and you
might start scratching your head and
thinking about now so many of you are
probably familiar with relational
database so this is something like like
Postgres or my sequel or something from
Oracle our VM or what have you I've
drawn it here as just a generic
relational database management system I
put it in red because these things are
usually pretty hot they're pretty busy
they're doing a lot of important
business stuff for you typically these
are handling things like your business
critical reads writes transactions when
customers show up and they make
purchases you write stuff down if
information contact information what
your customers changes you write that
down you're all these things to be
consistent this is in many cases your
source of truth for all of your
important business data no at the same
time in addition to doing these these
sort of interactive reads transactions
write stuff like that these database is
also managing another class of workloads
these I've drawn them a little bit
differently with bigger arrows because
they're a bit meteor and chunkier these
reporting and analytics and monitoring
tasks they're asking questions like how
many how many engagements did we have in
the past 24 hours
maybe you're monitoring some of your
system infrastructure so you're
wondering you know what are our KPI is
what are our latency is that we're
seeing when we're handing numbers back
to people just other analytics that you
might be looking at so up
mystic you know when people buy buy a
foo what do they also buy in the same
shopping basket you know we want to try
to figure those things out so that you
know either you sell more things and
make more money or or you learn a bit
more about your customers but this is a
class of workload that is I would
describe it as a little list in this
picture at least a little less
interactive you're not you're not
interacting with hot database you're
sort of landing on it and asking a big
query and getting the answer back and so
in the modern era of let's say data
warehousing type things the data these
queries land you know not so frequently
and refresh not so frequently and we're
gonna see if we can figure out how to
change that now the current state of the
world at least one of the current states
of the world we hear from from a bunch
of folks is if you want to address this
problem you know more and more analytic
queries of more and more complexity
people well the current tools for sure
in the database services aren't great
for this so people move towards
denormalization we're familiar with us
you take all of your exciting records
about interactions that people have had
with you and instead of saying you know
here's a customer ID go look up the
customer later you black down to
everything you know about the customer
right in line in these records you make
a relatively big wide tables of all of
your interaction so that when you come
and do these these analytics these these
reporting things you just aggregate up
running through all of this data you
know you count up for every what states
or something like this the amount of
sales you've done in it
and you were lucky that you wrote down
this date instead of just the customer
ID because that would have been a join
and that those are hard and so a lot of
people tweaked their internal data
architectures to look more like this D
normalized form a little less like a
relational database in a bit more like
what could be amenable to a stream
processor which which is is fine like
there's nothing fundamentally bad about
that it causes some challenges so the
good thing that happens I should say
sorry is that you're now able to cache a
fair bit more you able to push this
denormalized data out so that these
queries that come in can land in the
cache data and instead of performing a
complicated multi way join in your
relational database you can just read
some data right out of your cache in and
serve some answers on the flipside the
problem though is that life becomes a
little bit harder for everyone on the
the left side of the screen so these
reads transactions and writes have a lot
more work that they need to do when data
changes so like if a customer
changes their their contact information
they move from one state to another you
have the potential need to go rewrite
all of this data and all of these places
that you've scribbled down your your
specifics about each customer it would
have been helpful in that setting to
have left this as a customer basically
the primary key from from some customer
to all the information we know about
them and not have expended everything
out in place so in a lot of settings
this leads to ossification is it's hard
to change things someone shows up with a
new exciting bit of information they'd
like to write down about customers maybe
you have some engagement score that
you're trying out if you have to
scribble that down in every single place
that the customer is used that's a lot
of work to go and do and it makes it
hard for that person to try out a new
feature
similarly if someone comes in with a new
query and says oh I'd love to look at
you know our data aggregated this way we
hadn't realized we'd need before if
idiot isn't laid out correctly if it
hasn't been denormalized appropriately
maybe that's a non-starter maybe it
requires a lot of data engineering to
put that into place so this is you know
this can be a bit of an awkward pickle
here where you want to both support
these relational database interaction
modes and also larger aggregate queries
with prompt you know interactive vibe to
them as well
so that's that's what we're gonna we're
gonna talk about we're gonna talk about
taking this diagram and spinning it
around a little bit in a way that
hopefully you might have imagined in the
streaming space we're gonna let you
think of a relational database still is
a source of truth so people are
interacting with they're still using
their reads and their rights and their
transactional updates but rather than
try to land analytic queries onto the
relational database which isn't exactly
designed for this we're gonna think
instead of the database that's producing
exaust it's gonna be producing in in
different language change data capture
or SKU be producing changelog or bin log
basically we gave you a record of what's
happened in the database what records
have been added and removed to each of
the various tables and we're gonna feed
that into a data processing engine this
is gonna be materialized for this talk
so I'm sure all of you are familiar with
other sorts of platforms what I'm gonna
be doing for most of the time and this
talk is calling out the exciting ways
that materialises gonna be different
from these these things you might be
used to using and some of the cool
things that you can do with it that
other frameworks yeah you know aren't
quite active so now I'm gonna try to get
you excited about that and and tickle
your brain and get you thinking about
like wow I've really I could do this
that and the other thing that I've never
been able to do before that would be a
total
so so let's just let's let's start
actually what I thought I would start
with what I really thought I would start
with this is a live demo and I'm not
gonna do that because I was it was
implied that maybe that's an
irresponsible thing to do so what I've
done instead is I've captured a demo
there's just yesterday I just started
walking through some examples in our in
our system against a live running
installation I'm just gonna walk you
through its into a little little video
of this so materialist presents in a few
different ways it's presents as a
database and one way you can interact
with that is through just this equal
shell so we have we have a CLI here that
we use where you log in and you get it's
actually something like if you've used P
sequel or these other service tli tools
you know it's just an interactive
setting where you can look around you
can look at in this case sources these
are places we get data from for example
all of the my sequel things are a bunch
of relations we've pulled in from my
sequel instance nearby and they're
showing us a bunch of a bunch of data
inside them this is there's also some
logging stuff that we have here don't
don't get too excited about any of the
specifics here but as you can see one of
the things that you can do is just treat
this as a sequel instance so you can
count the number of records in each of
each of these relations this case order
line happens to be one of the the big
relations in the TPCC
benchmark this is a transaction
processing benchmark and the order line
thing is tracking a bunch of different
orders that have flown through or parts
of an order that have flown through some
big warehousing system and we're
counting the number of Records in it and
you can see that you know some million
odd records this isn't a particularly
big installation some million odd
records and it takes about half a second
and there's no particular reason to
think that that's great but you can do
it so so so great so what so this is one
way you can interact with the world what
materials could try to encourage you to
do those instead of writing de novo
sequel queries over and over again it's
gonna really try to draw out from you
the concept of a materialized view or
view it's gonna ask you to say hey maybe
what we should do instead of writing
this query over and over again is
announced this as a query of interest
and we do this in materialises you use
sequels create view
language to say we're creative you might
count as an exactly the same query from
before which has the nice property that
when we go and look at it now we're
gonna be maintaining this for you and
when you look at it instead of being
half a second it's tens of milliseconds
or so and you can just update it look at
it again you see the numbers are
changing the data are actually does this
database is changing it's undergoing a
few hundred records a second of turn and
we're giving out it turns out nice
consistent answers here these all of the
answers that materialized produces are
going to be the exactly correct answer
for the database at some point in time
appointed time that moves forward so uh
you know maybe this is interesting maybe
not yeah you're probably thinking like
okay count that's pretty amazing you
know I could probably do count too so
let's let's dial it up a little bit here
and do a few more interesting examples
so the next one the first query actually
from the from the workload we're using
this is a TP CH variant it's just a big
select that uses the same relation this
order line relation but it gets a bunch
of sums and averages and counts out as
well using various equal to diem some
filtering thrown in there as well and
it's all it's literally just sequel 92
nothing exotic about this this this
query language you can see bunch of
results up there don't worry about about
reading their particulars we're just
gonna go and instead of taking 0.8
seconds like we did here to the query
we're gonna create a view and with the
view created we're gonna see that it
takes a lot less time essentially to go
and dive in there and get the specific
data out again again tens of seconds
saying you know like 50 50 sorry tens of
milliseconds about 50 milliseconds 60
milliseconds in this case you can see
the data are changing and what we've
done just so this is totally transparent
we've pivoted the computation from one
that goes and tries to pull data out of
the out of the system and the standard
sequel evaluation technique to one that
reacts to change and we'll talk a bit
about the architecture for that in just
a moment once we once we've gotten
through this these examples we've turned
something that looks like a big database
II computation and something that looks
a bit more like a streaming computation
a reactive computation that updates in
response to change quite promptly now
you are all very clever people so
averages and sums and counts
again not not the world's most obscene
you could probably figure out if you
needed to how to write one of these
things yourself so so I'm gonna throw
out some stuff which is hopefully a bit
more terrifying
here's another query this is a four-way
joint you can see in the from field
there's four different relations there
customer's orders order lines new orders
we're joining all these together with
you can see about eight constraints down
there on various primary keys and it
takes in this case I don't know a second
or so to compute the answer the data
sets are not massive but we do exactly
the same thing create a joint it's
already created view my join up here
that is the exact same query and now
pulling out fresh results from this
joint is the sort of thing that I guess
we're gonna there's about three hundred
results in this joint so we could try to
limit it down to a small number is again
no tens of milliseconds to pop the date
out even though the joint is this weird
four-way join that involves a dumb bunch
of data shuffling and and and moving
stuff around once we've transformed the
computation into a reactive dataflow the
ability to update it is actually quite
brisk even though the original
computation might have involved reaching
around to all sorts of different sources
moving data around shuffling it
what-have-you so there's just a few more
little little blurb see that was that
was revenue ascending which is the wrong
way to look at large revenue numbers of
course that's the most exciting way to
look at them so if we just spin the
order around we haven't really changed
it well we certainly haven't changed the
the view might join very much so we can
get interactive access to the view by
descending revenue so we see big numbers
we can off there's some other cool
things which might not be obvious we can
the joins in the counts we've described
have been from base relations we can
write views that depend on other views
so here we're just creating a view that
selects the average revenue from from
the results of this joint this is now a
four-way join reduced down into total
revenue and then averaged across each of
the distinct orders and when we go and
pop stuff out of there we'll see again I
hope that it's again tons of tens of
milliseconds and you can refresh this to
your to your heart's content it you know
changes or it doesn't in this particular
case let's see we've refreshed it and
nothing's act
changed and you've probably seen that
before if you use streaming systems Wow
nothing changed that's that's not super
exciting you know how fresh is this data
it's a legit question you might ask I
haven't actually told you yet we're
gonna see in just a moment I'll point
out by the way the third one did refresh
so it does things do actually change but
it's legit to ask you know by how much
is this trailing trailing our input and
one of the fun things about materialized
there's one thing I find quite fun is
that we expose a lot of our internal
system state through relations so you
can actually introspect on this and ask
what is the relationship between the the
times essentially at which each of these
views are current one of the views that
we published is this perfect dependency
frontiers and we're about to sort of
pull out that data and that tells us for
each of the views that we're tracking
what are the essentially that the lags
between the output of the view and the
input to the view and we'll just sort of
read this out here so you recall my
Avenue which is right in the middle my
average depends on my join it turns out
that it has 0 milliseconds of lack at
the time of reporting this view which
means the results my average is
surfacing if we were to query it or
exactly the correct answer for my join
my join well depends on a few things it
was this four-way join and it's lagging
a few single-digit milliseconds behind
those input sources and like no joke
exactly correct answer is strongly
consistent these are exactly the results
correct circa three seconds ago so so
anyhow this hopefully gives you a sense
for the some of the capability is
something that materialized writing
interesting complicated sequel queries
involving joins of many relations and
actually insisting on and receiving
relatively low latency guarantees I'm
hesitant to say real-time because
everyone else is not hesitant to say
real-time but quite quite fast faster
than basically other other systems so
okay that's that's the that's the demo I
think it's worked out great
I'm gonna show you a few other things so
this demo was picked because I imagine
that that several of you might might
resonate with sore CLI a type tools or
at least not be as allergic to them as
as other people there are other ways
that materialize presents so this is
some of the some open source bi tools
out there this is meta base in
particular but because materialise
presents as something that looks a bit
like a relational database looks like
Postgres currently we're using PG wire
you can attach other types of BI tools
to materialize and there they're
currently programmed to think like wow
queries gonna take about a minute or two
I better not do them that often and in
because in Midway's we had to dive in
there and convince it to refresh once
every second instead of once every
minute because we can handle it just
fine but if you imagine using the
existing crop of BI tools if you're
familiar with them in a much more
interactive manner something where you
actually watch the data change second by
second instead of hitting refresh once a
minute and scrubbing around in the data
that's sort of the look and feel that we
were going for so with this in mind what
I thought I'd do with with the remaining
time is talk you through a bit more of
the architecture underneath the system
to get you you know if you're currently
thinking like wow that's amazing I
wonder how he does that stuff I'll I'll
talk through that if you're not thinking
that ask you to watch the first part of
the talk again and so let's talk a bit
about the architecture we're gonna
return to that picture before with the
relational database it's gonna show up
on this on a slide I've described
materialized here and visually as three
different layers don't assume anything
about the ordering it just a picture
works out better this way so at the
bottom at the sort of the access point
to materialise we have a bunch of
clients these are the sequel clients a
lot like the the CLI that we saw in the
demo where someone just connects and
starts typing similarly someone can
disconnect and start typing sequel or in
principle other sorts of interfaces if
you're using something like meta base
it's also going to connect as a client
and start asking queries and building up
session the state and prepared
statements and stuff like that all these
clients go in to a coordinator so this
is a central access point for
materialized and this is a moment where
essentially all of the clients can you
know indirectly interact so they share
state a little bit they can reuse the
same the same views and names with other
clients so if I created my joint
yelled out to someone hey Craig by the
way who's also here from materialised
sorry I should have said this you know
in Craig's like oh sweet my abs equals
da-da-da-da-da this works totally fine
right so we share all these things if
you have a you know this collaborative
data analysis team that some people
build some views and just ship them over
to other people works works great the
coordinator is what mediates all of that
it's also what decides if three of us
want to call something my join at the
same time who wins and basically
provides guarantees of consistency and
durability and whatnot that an actual
database it would be expected to provide
and up top we have timely data flow
workers and if you're familiar with the
work that I do that's this is where I
show up this is the data parallel
compute backplane and that is what's
going to get all of this work done all
of the incremental view maintenance high
performance I throughput stuff happens
back there so when we look at how these
are we interact with these layers the
clients is sequel I put sequel actually
this is not a sequel inspired language
this is not sequel with a bunch of
caveats where you can only do insertions
it's not you know sequel where you need
to know what's a stream and what's a
table or anything like that its sequel
you write a thing in sequel we give you
the correct answer we maintain the
correct answer no matter how your data
change insertions deletions don't care
so it's sequel 92 if you need with
recursive talk to us but the
intermediate representation that then
goes into we do some standard database
analysis at this point the world is a
little different in the streaming space
a lot of the analysis you would do in a
database essentially are targeting other
performance characteristics that then
what we're worried about so we're very
worried for example about this standing
memory footprint of these queries we're
gonna install this data flow it's a
thing that a database doesn't
necessarily worry about too much because
queries are ephemeral so we're we're
gonna be looking a little differently at
these queries to make sure that the
system doesn't fall over and then up top
the timely data flow system uses a
primary called differential data flow
which is again what was work that I've
done in the past that's really good at
incremental maintenance of relational
data parallel computation so things like
joins and aggregations and and
what-have-you and these connect to the
outside world and sort of schematically
this
anyway we saw before there's a
relational database that's that's pretty
loaded with a bunch of work going on
people are buying things from you or
people are visiting your website or your
logs are spitting out information all
that information flows into materialized
we're currently using a bridge called
the museum that drops things into Kafka
but there are a lot of ways that in
principle you can get data into into
materialized it's a pretty simple format
the horizontal lines here are the data
plane so this is meant to be this high
throughput low latency and generally
generally solid you know strongly
consistent compute infrastructure going
this way that is controlled by the
control plane which is this vertical
dimension so clients come in they talk
to the coordinator the coordinator sets
up some data flow and then the data just
move through that as promptly as
possible as fast as we can manage
essentially and on the right hand side
iya if you want write this out to
something like Kafka that's great that
the clients can also just interactively
peek at this data and look at it and see
what's in it but if you're looking for
high throughput data transforms sending
it back out to Kafka is totally sane in
principle we could you know we could
also present as a read replicas for for
a database that's not something we're
currently doing but we have lots of lots
of options if you're if you're
interested definitely let us know
because we have a lot of we have some
free cycles I think about what we want
to do next so I'm gonna just sketch out
is some of the cool internal
architecture to the materialized compute
backplane that makes it different from a
lot of the other systems you might be
familiar with different from things like
let's say k streams are different from
flink different from basically just
about everything else one of the big
important differences is that in timely
data flow we're gonna be building up
data flows I'm gonna start drawing
pictures of data flows in just a moment
but the data flows are all charted in
the sense that we might have multiple
workers let's say there's four workers
in this picture each of them are going
to be executing the same data flow there
could be executing fragments of exactly
the same data flow we're not going to
partition up work between the workers
when we say join all of the workers are
going to help out compete in the join
when we say reduce all of the workers
are gonna help out computing the reduce
there's a good reason for that and the
example is gonna try to build up and
show you what that good reason is so
let's just let's just start out you
might have create
a source here orders I've just made this
up but in in materialize you'd announce
a source which is something like you
know let's say a Kafka topic that's
meant to hold some sort of changelog
coming out of your relational database
will run off and will grab that will
start pulling in the data for you and
drop it into a named thing orders here
so it schematically these these green
widgets represent materialized charted
indices and this is one of the important
concepts in materialized so these
material I started indices as three
words in there they're all important
so the materialized in the sense that we
have actually collected the accumulated
changes that have gone on and we're
sitting on so someone if someone comes
and asks us now hey tell me about orders
like I'm super interested to hear about
how about orders what's the count of
everything in orders we need to actually
have that data around right if it washed
past and we let it go we don't really
have an answer for you anymore and we
feel really bad like we're not giving
you the correct answers anymore
this is absolutely going to materialize
the stream that has come through we're
going to accumulate up all of the
changes pluses and minuses and keep a
representation of the current state of
affairs for for orders and in fact a
little bit of historical detail for it
it is charted in the sense that the four
workers in this in this picture are each
maintaining a roughly one fourth of the
data and if you want you can think about
this is being charted up by like primary
key or something like that if orders
have a primary key we will have
distributed those keys across each of
the four workers and each worker is now
roughly handling about a fourth of this
data in their indices in the sense that
they are and in every case going to be
indexed by some important quantity if
it's a primary key that's that's a great
example will index them by primary key
so in the future if people need access
to this data by primary key a common
thing in a join will just have have
access to it ready to go with no
additional data manipulation required so
we'll see a few more of these material I
started indices again they're a pretty
important concept I'll call it a few
more reasons that they're important but
let's imagine someone someone shows up
with another source order some customers
and we then you know get asked to join
them and reduce them and I just imagine
that sales I had a bunch of other things
but it turns out like putting sales and
profit and stuff like that on the right
hand side makes people feel really good
about about things instead of like
defects or
what have you but um throwing down these
these additional bits of data flow can
be relatively cheap if we're already
sitting on these materialized started
indices imagine a world this is this
doesn't make a lot of sense in this
example actually but imagine world where
orders and customers were both charted
by their their primary key already and
we were joining on these keys that
doesn't make a lot of sense because
their primary keys for each of each of
the relations but bear with me we would
not need to move any of the data
associated with orders and customers
around they're already co-located
appropriately on their workers
partitioned by key thank you and we are
we're good to go
essentially the operators hear things
like join and reduce and whatnot are all
designed to be these reactive
implementations that as changes flow in
from the sources and into these indices
with indices also present changes
outwards they're implemented as
operators that are able to produce the
correct output changes alright so as you
know say five new orders show up the
join operators give you smart enough to
say who those might match with the
customers I better look up and see if
these five things hit over in customers
and produce any new matches in the
output if a customer's retracted for
some reason I don't know why maybe
they're not not so happy the joint will
need to think about should I be
retracting anything from my from my
output the video is similarly will
update their their aggregations or
accumulations correctly at the same time
so let's let's do a cool kiss of these
charted data flows being being used
excitingly I just put together another
parts source and let's say now that I
want joined that was sales sales is that
materialized index over on the right
there these are the same thing not
everything not only are they
conceptually the same thing materialists
are actually the same in memory index so
if someone wants to start using sales
they just grab that pointer and start
working with it which is really really
cool sorry they I mean the materialized
system in response to them typing join
but we're able to just grab this this
pointer and start working with it rather
than reflowing the full contents of
sales off to some other machine that's
gonna build up another index of it
anywhere anything like that so if we had
to join hypothetically with sales and
imagine that parts was a relatively
small so the sales is lots a gigabytes
and parts is a few thousand records
turning on this data flow is a matter of
milliseconds it's just
of synchronizing between the workers we
don't actually have to flow sales
anywhere and the thousand records that
come in from parts a thousand serve
changes from the initially empty
collection just result in lookups and
sales and you actually get the answers
back if there's only the say thousands
of records and parts in again
milliseconds or so so you're not
actually regrinding through these large
data sets that you've already maintained
in indexed form and this is perhaps one
of the most important points of
departure from other systems in the
space that have adopted you know to
their credit these pure streaming
architectures where there is no
persisted or maintained state there's a
downside to that and that means that is
regrinding through these large volumes
of data each time you need to use them
so let me explicitly call out a few good
things that these that these things do
and then I'll wind down and we can sort
of swing into question question
answering asking and answering mode so
the main point technical point I'd love
to make here is that these material I
started in indices improve several
things so they improved throughput in
the sense that instead of keeping five
copies of of one indexed collection
we're just keeping one that means that
we do a lot less work as we're receiving
your data we can handle higher loads of
changes coming in they improve latency
in several ways but we're latency is one
that I just called out so the amount of
time between you finish typing the query
you press Enter and we're able to start
giving you answers back is potentially a
lot lower if we're already sitting on
the index representations of the data
assets we need to start answering the
questions so this takes things from
potentially you know multiple seconds
down to milliseconds if we're working
especially if you're interrogating large
collections so if you're going in and
saying like I'm really interested in
this known subset of you know people
who've complained there's sent me emails
in the past day I want to go and look up
what their experience was a relatively
small set against the big set this will
come back in milliseconds and
continually update as opposed to you
know spinning up a data flow yeah you
can tell me how long this take a really
important thing that I think of not a
lot of people look at is query scaling a
meaning as more and more queries show up
so as your data analysis team grows if
it's just one person asking one word
count query great you know we can we can
draw that on the board if it's one
person asking five queries or twenty
people each asking ten queries what are
the resources required for that do you
actually
need to get in that case 200 times as
many resources as for that one data flow
and one of the really nice things that
goes on to materialise is that if people
are reusing the same data assets they
can start asking more questions
so as so long as you know the number of
distinct uses of the underlying data
aren't necessarily growing for at least
as those grow thank you
as those grow you need more resources
but if people are just reusing the same
customers relation the same source data
files you don't necessarily need to to
invest in a lot more resources there's a
lot of really nice sharing that happens
that makes querying pretty scaling
increasing a larger larger teams without
blowing your cloud budget all right so
uh take-home take-home points
last slide and then I'm gonna I'm gonna
stop one of the one of the goals that
materialized is to try to encourage
people may not be the right audience but
encourage people to replace some of the
the microservice morass out there which
is a lot of people writing thousands of
lines of java trying to make sure they
covered the various cases of people
reading from this to the other to the
extent that you can replace that with
ten lines of something like sequel that
just declaratively states this is what I
want someone else is gonna handle making
this work out correctly great you don't
have to stop doing the stuff that you
like but you can focus more of your
attention on the hard cases let the easy
cases be handled by my system that sort
of means to do this well and put a bunch
of engineering in it so outsource the
complexity of the easy things that you
can describe to us and there's a new
cool thing that you can do that I'd love
to get people to say anything about
which is this interactive analysis
against live data so a lot of prior
systems either the data comes in and
relatively slow chunks you know once
every hour or something like that your
data warehouse gets refreshed only so
fast or in streaming systems where the
data moves fast your ability to launch a
new query and get results back is gated
a bit by the time to build and deploy
these data flows we're actually able to
do both of these inter millisecond
timescales so you have the ability to
interactively explore data and learn
about it and understand it and ask what
question do I need to ask next and
respond to the data that I'm just seeing
interactively I get a lot of you are
probably familiar with DevOps style
problems something is on fire in your
computers how long does it take you to
figure out what the answer to that and
you know you start asking some questions
you really want to know what the current
state of affairs is as soon as you see
that you think of a different question
to ask all right there isn't just a
standard
questions you you need to know this is
something that we think is is really
opening up now and we love to try to get
our head around what are all the
exciting use cases here how much power
does this give people what would people
do with it so I'm gonna wind down there
I apologize I went a little bit late but
there's some contact information you can
read all about us here at material I
said oh actually there's a few places to
check out online
macelli's is one that's that's us the
organization the underlying compute
substrate is all publicly accessible
open source all that stuff you can find
that at at timely data flow on github
I'm Franklin cherry chief scientist at
materialized feel free to contact me
using my very professional email here
and if you'd prefer to be unprofessional
my twitter handle is down there and this
is a great way to bait me into to
responding to your concerns in a more
public forum but I'm gonna stop with
that I appreciate the time you've given
me and we have I believe some time for
questions on a very left site that's
like one database can you materialized
its data from like multiple databases
yes okay good the question is if you're
just mirroring one database the story
might be relatively see what happens
with multiple data sources it's a great
technical question operationally the
underlying compute substrate can there
is the differential data flow substrate
hensel's is this cool thing called multi
temporal data flow where so if you like
think of the timestamp seems to these
systems as the commit IDs like a GT ID
and in my sequel which is sort of you
know consistent view of the database
consistent view the database consistent
view of the database if you've got two
of these that are marching forward that
are unrelated you need some sort of
story but how do i how do I talk about
these two different notions of time at
the same time and the as best as I
understand the academic underpinning of
this is this concept of multi temporal
analysis we have essentially two
dimensions of time they happen to go
along largely together but you need to
think about them separately the
underlying substrate supports that
materialize itself at the moment does
not our times are integers but it's you
know easy enough to to think about
changing that around as people show up
and say this is this is crucial for us
I don't know if that's the short answer
is not right now that we'd love to know
if that's important we totally could do
this
given enough time and like if everyone
the room said yes that's what we need we
would absolutely go into it right away
thank you for you to talk about was
great
one question maybe two questions be
honest and the first one you mentioned
that you stream or you get change lock
you mentioned change lock flu cough cut
do to your system to materialise and the
question is do you mean by change look
at the right a headlock which is a
technical term for from like the change
change that in relational databases and
if yes then how you monitor that how you
really like string that how you connect
to that to you know to push it into
Kafka so the first question and the
second question is the demo was great
but I noticed that when you create a
view it takes from tens milliseconds and
is that real I mean or is it just you
know the the the execution of the
parsing SQL and then in the background
is the whole like real materialization
of the so great two questions so the
first sent one has a very easy answer
there's an existing project called the
Museum that means to be a bridge from
several different existing databases
into a Kafka changelog style feed so
they're monitoring the the bin logs and
depending on the the particular database
the right ahead log in some cases doing
a little bit of magic there because not
all of them present exactly the right
information but they present a stream of
for each record that before and after
if you have that record in the example
the demo the view creation absolutely
you're absolutely right that is setting
up metadata and it's it's building the
data flow and it's starting to stream
data in so if I were incredibly fast at
typing I could have created a view and
then then looked at it immediately and
you might have seen data that was a bit
stale because the view had not yet fully
populated this is this is what we use
these like the last part of the demo was
information about the lag on these
things and that's something that would
initially at the moment of creation show
Wow quite a lot of lag you know like we
often see something like you know 47
years of leg
I guess 49 years of like now because
when it starts at 0 that's you know you
next time and and but pretty quickly
these things fill out sorry you're
behind someone
these things fill out and absolutely you
want to dive back into that that logging
reporting relation to make sure that you
you see the right stuff there
[Music]